قبل ايام زلزال تركيا وتحديدا قبل ثلاثه
ايام توقع باحث هولندي حدوث وقوعه وذكر
الدول التي ستتاثر بالزلزال كتب الخبير
الهولندي والباحث في شؤون الزلازل فرانك
هوجيتس كتب في تغريده ان زلزالا سيحدث
بقوه 7.5 درجات مئويه في منطقه جنوب وسط
تركيا والاردن وسوريا ولبنان وحذر في
تغريده اخرى من الارتدادات التي تتبع
الزلزال وشددا على ضروره مراقبه النشاط
الزلزال القوي الاضافي في وسط تركيا
والمناطق المجاوره قائلا انها عاده ما
تستمر لفتره من الوقت بعد وقوع زلزال كبير
[موسيقى]
على كل حال تغريده فرانكو كانت محطه
تساؤلات الكثيرين خاصه اهل الاختصاص في
الجغرافيا البيئه والزلازل حتى انه عاد
واكد تغريدته مفتخرا انه كان يعلم بالرغم
من ان هناك اجماعا لدى الخبراء على صعوبه
التنبؤ بالزلزال قبل حدوثه لكن ايضا
الذكاء الاصطناعي يزاحم الباحثين في
الجيولوجيا دخل عالم التنبؤ بالكوارث
يتابع معكم في الشرح التالي
ولكن قبل ان نذهب الى الشرح نذهب الى
ضيفنا من القاهره الذي اصبح جاهزا معنا
استاذ الجيولوجيا في جامعه القاهره عباس
شراقي اهلا بك استاذ عباس معنا في صباح
العربيه يسعد صباحك استاذ عباس عندما نقرا
هذه التغريده الصادمه والتي قراها الجميع
والعالم متاخرا خصوصا بعد ثلاثه ايام يعني
تخطر في بالنا تساؤلات علميه كيف يمكن
التنبؤ بالزلازل قبل وقوعها هل هناك
دلالات اشارات معينه
صباح الخير عليك يا استاذه نادين وكل
الساده المشاهدين
ونتمنى ان شاء الله هذا اليوم يكون يوم
هادئ على المنطقه
ولا نشهد مزيد من الزلازل هو حقيقي كان في
حوالي عشر زلازل خلال الساعتين الماضيتين
ولكن زلازل اقل من المتوسط يعني بين اربعه
وخمسه
وده يعني بالمقارنه ما يبقى لهمش تاثير
كبير ولكن احنا يعني برضو نلاحظ ان في بعض
المباني اللي فيها بعض التصدعات يؤثر
عليها الزلازل حتى المتوسطه لانها هي
بالفعل
تصدعك بالنسبه
للتنبؤات بالزلازل علميا لا يوجد وسيله
علميه حتى الان او اي جهاز
لتحديد موعد زمني لحدوث زلازل ولكن ممكن
يبقى في بعض التوقعات في شواهد يعني مثلا
في بعض الاماكن بيحدث فيها زلازل يوميا
زاد هذا المعدل عن المتوسط ده بيبقى زي
اشاره ان ربما يحدث زلزال هنا برضو نقول
ربما يحدث زي الكبير والحقيقه يعني احنا
لا نلجا الى هذا يعني التنبؤ لان ده ممكن
يعمل ذعر شديد تخيلوا لو احنا مثلا قلنا
من اسبوعين تلاته ان في زلزال ممكن يحصل
فيها هنعمل ايه للسكان في تركيا الزلزال
هيحصل فين في تركيا ما هي تركيا مساحه
كبيره للغايه عندنا من الشرق للغرب 1500
كيلو الناس تروح فين هل في الشرق الناس
تروح الغرب ولا من تركيا كلها هنا اذا
احنا تنبانا لهنا لازم لازم التلبؤ يكون
يعني محدد
بمنطقه وبزمن بحيث ان بالفعل يعني نقدر ان
احنا نخلي السكان من هذا المكان لكن مش
ممكن يخلص سكان دوله وان الكلام بيبقى كده
على اطلاقه ايضا لما يعني لما نقول ان في
زلزال هيحصل في هذه المنطقه وان في دول
مثلا تركيا وسوريا والاردن اي زلزال هيحصل
في تركيا هيؤثر على هذه الدول يعني ما هي
دي هذه هي دول الجوار وبالتالي ليس بجديد
ان احنا نقول مين اللي هيتاثر لكن تحديد
الزلزال في وقت معين علميا لا يوجد اي
وسيله او اي جهاز حتى في امريكا
مع اهل الاختصاص في الذكاء الاصطناعي هذه
المره استاذ عباس حتى التنبؤزات
الاستداديه التي تلي الزلزال لماذا يخشاها
الناس هل حجم الضرر يوازي حجم الزلزال وهل
يمكن ايضا التنبؤ بحجمها وقعها متى
احنا يعني برضو بتيجي من الخبره بتشوف
الزلازل القديمه ماذا حدث في زلزال قوي
حدث وبعديه منه في بتيجي توابع وبتقعد
ايام قد ايه هذه تاتي من الخبره وليس
نتيجه ان في جهاز بيقول ان هيحصل كذا ما
حدث في تركيا امس هذا شيء غير مسبوق في
التاريخ لان لم يحدث زلزال واحد احنا يعني
تم تسجيل حتى الان حوالي 300 زلزال 300
زلزال خلال 24 ساعه هذا عدد ضخم وبعدين
هذا العدد ليس في مكان واحد يعني صحيح
المكان الرئيسي هو هو في الخط
البرتقالي اللي موجود في الصوره في في
المنطقه الحدوديه ما بين تركيا
وسوريا هذا الحزام هو اللي فيه الكثير من
الزلازل لكن شفنا زلازل في وسط
تركيا بالقرب من انقره شفنا
في غرب تركيا على سواحل البحر المتوسط حتى
شفنا زلازل في جزيره قبرص فبالتالي هذا
الكم من الزلازل الموزع وزلازل منفصله
وبالتالي هنا ليست كلها توابع يعني في
يعني منقول عندنا يجي خمسين موقع للزلازل
في تركيا هذا غير مسبوق واحنا شفنا يعني
من التقرير وان ان في الاحداث المشابهه في
سنه 39 كان زلزال يعني يعادل تقريبا لان
سبعه وثمانيه من عشره الزلزال اللي حصل
امس الرئيسي وراح ضحيته 33,000 في وقت سنه
39 كان عدد السكان تركيا يمكن ربع العدد
الحالي
يعني المدن كانت ليست بالكثافه الحاليه
وبالتالي يعني هنا التوقع الان احنا نتمنى
ان العدد لا يزيد ولكن الحقيقه للاسف
الواقع بيقول ان في الاف تحت الانقاذ
نتمنى ان النهارده فرصه ان احنا نلاقي
احياء لان بالوقت بيمر بيبقى في صعوبه ان
احنا هنلاقيهم احياء يعني هم دلوقتي تحت
الانقاذ بانهم اكثر من 24 ساعه وربما في
بعضهم للاسف انتهى الوقت للاسف انتهى
الوقت حديث فعلا يعني مهم وضروري في هذه
الايام شكرا جزيلا لك من القهر استاذ
الجيولوجيا في جامعه القاهره عباس شرقي
شكرا لك